nicknamed the uber for dogs and dog B&B
wagon Rover are popular apps that are
transforming the pet care industry now
these apps offer on-demand dog walking
and dog sitting services right through
your phone but a growing number of
reports of dogs being mistreated are now
raising new questions about how well
these apps screen their walkers and
their sitters chip readers in Washington
with a closer look at all of this chip
good morning to you well good morning
wagon Rover have made it easier than
ever to find someone to walk and watch
your pets and these companies are
cashing in both are valued in the
hundreds of millions of dollars but
while the potential for profit is high
so are the stakes we spoke with one
woman who blames Rover for the death of
her dog he was the one dog that was
meant for me Coleen Nolan says she built
her life around her 12 year old Japanese
chin named Mushu adopted it eight weeks
old when a work trip came up last year
Nolan says she was worried about leaving
him Mushu was not just old he was blind
I wanted to make sure that he was
comfortable in his surroundings that he
stayed in the home so I reached out to
Rover to try to find a sitter Rover and
wag are popular apps that connect pet
owners with walkers and sitters they
advertise rigorous screening and
background checks Nolan says she chose a
Rover sitter who had badges on her
profile for working with senior and
special-needs dogs my little munchkin
Nolan says she gave the sitter specific
instructions bushu was to be taken out
of the house only for short walks those
instructions she later learned were
ignored you got an emergency text from
the dog sitter and what did it say I
called her and I said what happened and
she said moosh fell off my porch fell
off her porch yes and I said what do you
mean your porch because she was supposed
to stay right here right like how far
did he fall
and she she said two stories two stories
that's not a porch Nolan says Rover
offered to cover half of the expenses
following Moo shus death including vet
bills cremation and the cost of a new
dog totaling $2,600 but with one
condition sign a strict confidentiality
agreement never tell my story - never
more than any other parent so what did
you do I never called them back
Rover advertises that fewer than 20% of
sitters who apply are accepted they say
all must pass a background check and be
approved by a team of specialists what
was your understanding of Rover and
their selectivity I thought that with
Rover saying that they only select a
small few and that the han review each
one of these sitters that clearly those
badges hadn't mean that they they
embedded that nolan's is not the only
case CBS News spoke to 14 families who
say their dogs died while in the care of
Rover or wag sitters 12 of those
incidents involved Rover sitters one
user said she discovered her Rover
sitter had a criminal record and users
of both apps told us they were also
asked to sign non-disclosure agreements
following incidents in December a wag
Walker was caught on surveillance video
kicking and intimidating a dog wag is
currently being investigated by the
Better Business Bureau over claims made
in their advertisements including that
walkers are vetted through a rigorous
screening process in a statement to CBS
News wag told us that in addition to
background checks they collect real-time
information through the app to regularly
assess Walker's Rover told us sitters
must also provide photos testimonials
and pass a safety quiz just pasting a
badge on the website is not going to
work any more they're going to have to
back that up with some kind of training
pet care industry experts such as Carmen
roost in Beck says the industry is
beginning to adopt more regulations but
for now pet owners should be looking for
pet care providers with professional
licenses
if you had a child would you just accept
a person on an app to take care of your
child or would you do more investigation
and that's when I encourage all pet
owners to do Rover and wag told us that
incidents like Nolan's are rare but they
declined to provide exact numbers but in
a document obtained by CBS News from a
lawsuit against Rover in California
Rover says they don't keep track on
their platform of how many dogs have
died and they told us the well-being of
pets is their top priority and they are
continually working to improve safety
wag told us that they are committed to
constantly improving their service and
cared deeply about the safety of dogs
Norah important story chip thank you I
mean Lena do ya that's she raised a
really good point the woman at the end
where she said taking care of your
children and most people who have dogs
and love our dogs think of them as our
children certainly members of the family
and you wouldn't rely on someone to rely
on what you read on an app or what you
saw on an app she's very right about
that yeah that video guy is that a guy
kicking the dog right is one of the
cruelest things you can do yeah we're
defenseless little animal all right
there'll be more I think on this story
about the judge that they're gonna make
Noor I'm glad people are speaking out